did you know 40% 40% of fortune 500
companies in America are founded by an
immigrant or a child of an immigrant 40%
that's 200 of the biggest companies in
America that's a lot of numbers there
right and then you hear Inc magazines
say that immigrants are twice as likely
to become entrepreneurs than somebody
that's actually born here so why is that
why does that take place so today I'm
going to talk to you about the ten
reasons why immigrants make great
entrepreneurs and if you have any
questions thoughts comments make sure
you post your comments on the bottom and
if you haven't yet subscribed to this
channel click on the subscribe channel a
button here to see more videos on
valuating so let me get right into a
point number one think skin what do you
mean by thick skin let me explain it to
you there is something that happens when
I grow up in a very peaceful family with
no problems everything's covered things
are good things are smooth mom and dad
never argue everything's just chill you
know those families that they talk in
just everything is easy gone now I want
you to think about the other family okay
imagine you're in a family when you're
escaping a war you're getting bombed on
every week where your kids can't go play
outside because everybody is afraid
where mom and dad are afraid to go
outside and tensions higher you're
working longer hours you ain't got time
around your kid your tempers shorter you
got a shorter fuse you get upset at the
kids a little bit faster you give them a
look you know you push the kids around
parents have all this pressure on them
and you have to release it somewhere to
have the white presidency husband five
six days a week because he's out there
working and the only thing he sees or
she sees are the kids she has to release
that tension somewhere where else is it
going to go and the kid gets it right
now some people only say that's called
bad parenting unless if you've never
been in a situation like that you can't
see what it's like at the top but what
happens is there's a thick benefit to it
here's what the benefit is that kid says
if I can handle living with my mommy and
my daddy guess what I can handle
anybody else because my skin is so thick
now your little rejection saying no to
my proposal means nothing nothing
because I can live in this family with
this mommy and daddy I can definitely
handle you when you get sick skin the
world of business is so easy for you
because you're not worried about
somebody hurting your feelings number
two patients in the world of business
you're going to need a lot of patience I
remember living in Iran 1984 a my dad
and my mom finally deciding to apply for
a green card to come to America we would
watch rocky and 1985 when it came out
we'll watch all these movies about the
United States this is heaven people were
coming they were celebrating about
coming to America they got their number
they got the free ticket to come to the
land of all opportunities from 1984 we
waited till 89 Khomeini dies we still
don't have Oracle we don't have the
green card yet
how many does June 3rd six weeks later
we escaped when we go to Germany I live
in a refugee camp in Germany for a year
and a half then we finally get our
papers then we come to America November
28 1990 take seven and a half years
until we finally made it to the state it
requires a lot of patience until you get
what you want
same thing with business number three
long hours 9:00 to 5:00 is an American
thing there's not really a lot of 9:00
to 5:00 going out with immigrants
immigrants wake up in the morning and
their work will have the money on the
table to food on the table to go buy
stuff pay rent all the stuff with your
kids there is no nine-to-five it's not
like a nine-to-five and all these other
things you're dealing you get to work
and you come home and you make sure
everything is covered and typically
they're used to working six days a week
not five days a week in America they're
trying to go to four days a week they're
even trying to write a book called
4-hour workweek a guy named Tim Ferriss
liked work less immigrants say hey
everybody in America you guys keep
working four hours a week we're going to
bust our behinds and guess what 40% of
Fortune 500 companies will be founded by
us and our kids but you guys keep
working four hours a week leave that
market for us because we're not afraid
of hard work they bring that to the
table in the world of business if unions
raided this Oh everyone's going to
eventually find out about your business
if you're not afraid of this number four
they value money a little bit more
here's why I remember when we were
living in Germany at a refugee camp and
I wanted to go to a MOOC I don't think
we ever went to movies in Germany I
don't think we ever went to movies in
Germany so if we even had a chance to go
somewhere and do anything with it it was
like magical I remember being 11 years
old we played the first a lot
okay I found out about a lot Oh had
saved up five bucks and I went and
played gelato sometimes people ask me
how come I don't play the lottery I want
to play five bucks and I pick these
numbers I remember numbers till today 44
was one of them 16 was another one 38
was another I picked my mom's ages at
the time of dad's age at that time and I
came and I said oh my god I don't know
why I feel like I'm gonna win and we're
gonna be millionaires my mom made that
everybody's going to be good we're gonna
be taking care this is going to change
our lives but we didn't win I cried all
night like a little baby you know why
because you know how much was five marks
to our family man it was a lot of money
with five marks was so when you come to
the stage
you value money a little bit more
because you worked your tail for this
money so you understand we ain't wasting
this money here kid we ain't buying all
this nonsense stuff because you value
money a little bit more in the world of
business the more you can know how to
value money you know how to stretch that
doll your business last a lot longer
number five they're used to taking risks
uncertainty and risk is part of the life
I mean it depends on what part of the
country and world you come from I always
like to travel and go different places
and ask questions what is it like living
here tell me about it you know what the
average daily income people make what is
the income here we were in Cancun tell
me what people are making here we go to
the masks you tell me about what it's
like they're so used to risk in an
uncertainty they're so used to risk in
uncertainty it's like every day is a
risk every day is an uncertainty and in
the world of business it's the same
thing but most people cannot handle too
much risk and too much uncertainty most
people like a lot of things to be safe
they don't like too much risk they don't
like too much uncertainty and that's
what you're going to get into the
business world and you don't know how to
handle this all of us under two
shell-shocked I can't have the list you
go back to where you were doing before
but immigrants already know how to
handle the number six sacrifice
sacrifice could be on a lot of different
scales by the way time away from family
time away from party and time away from
full and on time so many different
things this is a must in the world of
business it's a must for what immigrants
do imagine if you already used to go
into the places you eat churches you go
to families you visit friends all this
stuff you accustomed to living around 4
5 10 15 20 30 40 years then all of a
sudden you pack your bags and leave
to go to a new place and you don't speak
the language you know how many
sacrifices you're making you're used to
it in a world of business they make easy
transition nothing a big sacrifice to
somebody else could be a small sacrifice
to an immigrant entrepreneur number
seven another level of commonalities
because of languages so think about it
imagine if me I remember when I joined
the army I went to px px is military's
Walmart I want 2 PX and I ran into
everybody at Fort Jackson South Carolina
at the time everybody was Caucasian
african-american Hispanic ok so here I
am walking I go to px and I see another
guy with a crooked nose I said wait a
minute I recognize crooked noses you
know middle Easterns we got these
crooked noses I said hey man were you
firm this is what you found I said I'm
from Glendale you know I'm half Armenian
after 6:00 there's no way up on Glendale
I'm army so you've got to be kidding me
so we connected there's a relationship
if we don't speak our language we don't
have that connection it's a whole
different story than friends that also
speak Armenian and Assyrian I get
connected to people that speak Farsi I
get connected to that because there's
another language you speak so if you do
business with somebody that speak
Spanish you can get into the community
people that speak Spanish I recently sat
with a guy here who's from Pakistan I
said what percentage of your businesses
would people who are Pakistani he says
95 percent he can connect with an
audience that you may not be able to
connect with because he is part of that
community is part of that culture it
helps in business as well so culturally
language it helps number-8 help
businesses go global so what's this this
Red Bull guys stories what Demetri some
strange lasting the founder of Red Bull
interesting story he apparently goes to
Thailand and in Thailand they're making
this drink is called krob dank or
something like that crop dank which in
the language means Red Bull so he says
my gosh what is his drink mate forces
for truck drivers so people don't fall
asleep she drinks it she likes it he
drinks it to America he started selling
it and put Red Bull on it and not his
work fifteen point seven billion dollars
on a drink called Red Bull you know how
many billions of you know Red Bulls you
have to sell to have a net worth the
fifteen point seven billion
that time and he saw what happened
globally connected so he knows because
he's connected to other places you're
constantly in another country you're
connected with other people you're not
worried about to go into another country
because you already used to it he brings
that idea back it helps a business out
here in America and all over the world
because everybody now not everybody but
billions of Red Bulls have been sold all
over the world number nine ownership
matters to them
why does ownership matter to them so we
had a story of this happened where we
were at but you hear this in different
types of countries as well where you own
a property all of a sudden government
comes and takes a property away from you
because hey we have a new law this is
our land you can't do nothing about it
here you go this is what you got
one-fifth of what the value is how I
stay quiet or else boom give us a
property of Scone right so you don't
really that on that idea of somebody
taking away your home from you or your
land for me it's like somebody saying
hey that's my girl give me your girl
it's my wife give me your wife that's my
wife anytime it's my wife no no it's my
wife after now here's ten grand walk
away don't complain she's my wife now
there kind of stuff that happens when
you your property that's my wife that's
my husband what is my ownership in the
world of business
immigrants love ownership because
they're all about freedom I want to have
control this is mine I worked my butt
off
leave me alone let me get to work and
let me have the life that I want to have
let me have the family that I want to
have because ownership matters that's
why they like being entrepreneurs the
number 10 they don't get spooked by
different cultures if a person is from
Mexico
no one gets shocked when they meet me
and I'm from Iran okay if I meet
somebody from a for-instance Africa and
I meet them that you're worried from out
from Iran they don't get spooked if I
meet somebody from Alabama and they ask
me where I'm from I say you're honest it
were you from from Iran what's the
biggie I never seen an Iranian before so
this is what you guys look like right
because there's no Iranians necessarily
in Alabama but a person who's an
immigrant
they conviction they can see anybody
because like I'm used to have another
kind of cultures I'm used to what it is
to come to America I can handle anybody
else because I've seen many different
kinds especially myself being an
immigrant coming here I don't have a
hard time transitioning with getting to
know other culture so I tell you all
this stuff because you hear all these
talks about
immigrants entrepreneurship all of these
things but but I want to I want to tell
the immigrants something here that maybe
you haven't been told because it's
always this idea about immigrants make
great entrepreneurs let me give you one
final thought to be thinking about on
immigrant entrepreneurs yes
40% of fortune 500 CEOs are immigrants
or the child of an immigrant that
started a company yes over 10 percent of
Forbes 400 richest men in America Forbes
400 richest men in America are
immigrants over 10 percent Elon Musk is
one of them said he a founder of Google
is another so there's there's a good
percent of our out there but how come
not more and what is the channel with
some other people maybe you're watching
this and how come not more how come now
yours if I come not somebody else
sometimes when you go from a horrible
situation you have to an incredible one
you settle for good because it's still
better than horrible just like man oh my
gosh I'm totally happy what I what I'm
doing right now
this is totally warm and fuzzy for me
I'm good I'm okay with this and
sometimes immigrants don't think big and
they settle you have all the abilities
to become a successful entrepreneur go
out there and win where you settle too
early and when you settle too early you
leave the upside potential for somebody
else to go out and capitalize on so if
you're watching this yourself say men
how many immigrant how come this hasn't
happened for me maybe you ought to start
thinking a little bit bigger maybe maybe
you ought to not just say I'm settling
and seeing everything is working out
it's better than what it used to be some
happy I'm grateful I'm good to go
keep being grateful but stretch you a
little bit more think a little bit
bigger see about the bigger
possibilities on what you can do with
your life instead of just saying I'm
doing better than my cousin's I'm doing
better than my uncle back in
such-and-such country I'm doing better
than my dad back in El Salvador
no you become the leader for everybody
else because you keep expanding yourself
to want to even something bigger again
question stops comment on the bottom if
you haven't subscribed click on the
subscribe button and a notification
button right next to it to be one of the
first again notified every time a new
video comes out say to everybody goodbye
[Music]